hello there Marvel Spider-Man 2 is
almost here since the first announcement
a handful of trailers have dropped each
with miscible information hidden inside
today we are going to find those details
those Easter eggs and those comic book
references here are 26 things you missed
in the Marvel Spider-Man 2 trailers
in the latest trailer we see Miles
Morales quickly switch by holding down
Square to become Peter in less than half
a second the switch has already taken
place and this time Peter is doing
gravity defying sit-ups this animation
is only one of many micro interactions
that will replace the subway scenes in
the first two games the similarities to
GTA 5 can't go unnoticed switching
between characters back then was
mind-blowing and I'm not sure we'll see
Peter in the same places we found Trevor
but it wouldn't be the first time we've
caught Peter in his tighty whities
previewers have said another micro
interaction sees Peter playing with a
spider bot as if no one is looking and
then suddenly realizing he's on duty
hopefully there are many of these
animations to discover it's also is
possible to spot the Spider-Man you are
not playing as on the map which once
again gives me GTA 5 Vibes as it was
possible to bump into them in the street
remember what happened if you did this
too much in Grand Theft Auto
[Music]
and in fact during play tests that
occasionally when arriving at a crime
scene the other Spider-Man is already
there allowing the two Spider-Man to
fight together which also confirms that
two-person takedowns are back and better
than ever we had them in the original
DLC with black cat and again with Miles
and the prowler in the second game the
latest gameplay trailers show how much
quicker the Spider Boys Can navigate the
city which is a good thing because the
playable area is now twice the size I
ran a quick test for myself lining up
the same location in the 2020 game as
though seen in the Spider-Man 2 trailers
I followed the same route and the old
Spider-Man took 40 seconds while the new
looks buddy took 20 seconds it wasn't a
scientific test but it was definitely
twice as fast and some Dev interviews
have said it might be three times as
fast that's just rapid the main upgrades
are that of a slingshot start and that
wing suit and of course the wind tunnels
we can travel through for uplift and
speed oh and another thing to note the
Harlem fish market in the new game was
not in the last game so it's not just
the new part of the map which is getting
some love before we move on a tiny
detail here which is amazing the
wingsuit design changes to suit the
Spider-Man suit you've selected Chef
kiss moment here while we're looking at
traversal it should be noted that the
traffic and number of pedestrians around
New York looks to be denser than ever I
did my best to revisit the same spots in
the 2018 Remastered game to check it out
and definitely there's a lot more going
on vertically there are more civilians
too we've spotted people in apartments
and office blocks looking out the window
in gameplay trailers this kind of
existed in 2018 but only for a certain
Mission or two and building Interiors
back then use this Parallax scrolling
technique which made dolls inside lead
to literally nowhere it looks like
Insomniac are cleaning up that part of
Spider-Man 2. oh and one more traversal
tidbit if I may once unlocked we can
fast travel anywhere at all literally
select the middle of the map and one
second later you are there this must be
the greatest fast travel ever created at
one point in the New York trailer
Spider-Man 2's creative director Brian
interhar says this others will lead to a
climactic showdown on Marvel villains
not yet seen in this Spider-Man universe
so we are indeed getting more super
villains and I think we've already
spotted three already and I don't mean
venom lizard and Craven first wraith was
confirmed on the map of flyover that
introduced Craven and if you've played
through the 2018 DLC you'll know all
about Yuri Watanabe a police captain
Peter worked alongside who tried to do
everything by the book but that cost
innocent lives and she slowly went off
the rails and became a new anti-hero of
sorts targeting Untouchable crime bosses
this has to be her new wraith get up
spotted in the sky are these green
symbols which must be the confirmation
that Mysterio is coming to the world he
she they was in the original game but
that was a costume party the new
Mysterio hasn't been spotted in His
official gear yet but it's a safe bet to
say that this is the everyday look of
Quentin Beck this next one may be a shot
in the dark but I think this guy here
could be one of butane's minions I tried
to look for Marvel characters with fire
abilities from the Human Torch to a dude
called Fire Monster but the closest I
could find was butane the redesign for
the Spider-Man freshman year project
coming soon they generally match up
visually but I'm not confident with this
so let's leave butane and crack on back
when Coney Island was revealed and the
fun fair the guys visited there was a
few Marvel super villain character
Easter eggs spotted around like this one
big wheel who is my favorite Marvel
villain of all time Jackson Axel wheel
who gets around on a literal Ferris
wheel what is not to love the hydro
bench stall here must be a nod to hydro
man who fell into the sea near an
experimental generator and became human
water and his name was Maurice bench so
Hydro man Morris bench Hydro bench and
there's also a ride called Speed Demon
who is effectively Marvel's version of
The Flash just a little more evil with
already started geeking out so let's go
through some of the suits in the
trailers when we finally get our hands
on Spider-Man 2 there will be over 65
suits to unlock and over 200 variations
thanks to a new Shader system but that's
not it as the eagle-eyed have noticed
that suits from the previous games are
making a comeback the 2099 miles suit
the tracksuit and Mild spots where
variants all come back and won't be left
behind and then we have the new suit and
a blink and you'll miss it speed edit
here's just a few of them Peter's
military inspired Civil War suit from a
time when Dr Doom created alternative
universes which began to Splinter he
also had a spider Falcon variation
complete with wings which could be in
Spider-Man 2 as the wingsuit this shot
transitions into the suit we begged for
for years the Sam Raimi Spider-Man 3
symbiote suit bully Maguire memes will
be coming when the game releases I'm
gonna put some dirt in your eye the
arachnite suit is from a time when
Gamora created a warped world and
Spider-Man and Moon Knight merged into
one being miles on the other hand can be
spotted wearing his Puerto Rico suit
which I had to double check wasn't the
Captain America Miles Morales and it
definitely isn't this is Puerto Rico and
finally I believe this suit is from The
Superior Spider-Man run from a Time Dr
Doom took over the Earth and I just
realized that Dr Doom really should be
the main bad guy in the next game
another suit that needs attention is
this
changes thanks to a new ability
confirmed it's essentially rage mode
from God of War giving the Venom
abilities a bit more spice and if the
comparison is to God of War you'll know
this ability will be absolutely epic
during these moments your suit will
change and become more like the Venom
Suit you're familiar with almost like
Peter is being overtaken by that
symbiote there's a tonmar suit ranging
from new to OG and I'll break those down
nearer the time the game releases this
was just a day stuff back to the
trailers and we briefly see spider bots
around the city which act as act as
collectibles in Spider-Man 2. what is
most impressive here is that previewers
have said that each bot represents a
Spider-Man or a super villain from
Another Universe essentially confirming
the Multiverse theory is part of the
game the side quest can be followed
through to a conclusion but right now
nobody knows what will happen and who
will be behind these mini crossover
events I'm still praying for Dr Doom
the combat system in Spider-Man 2 has
evolved and the new Parry Dodge system
has arrived very basically a red circle
around an attack is a prompt to Parry
the hit and immediately fight back
whereas a blue circle indicates that
this attack is unparriable and must be
dodged it's a simple mechanic but it'll
sure increase difficulty for fans who
want more of a challenge this time
around oh and take a look see bosses now
have health bars a minor annoyance in
the original games was that we had no
idea if our attacks were doing the right
kind of damage and we basically hopped
to trigger the next part of the fight in
Spider-Man 2 we know for sure the health
bar means no one is guessing this time
around I could talk about this game for
hours but I think that's enough for day
one I have 11 Spider-Man videos coming
over the next month or so so please
subscribe for more I'm Adam you're
awesome see you next time
the world